it is time for another pokemon presents
everybody i am really excited
to watch this because i am
super excited about these two new
pokemon games i feel like more excited
than i have been for a pretty long time
in no small part due to
the co-op news i think that that's going
to be so so so much fun but also
just you know i'm into the world i'm
into the vibe i like the look of the
villains a whole lot um
i hope we see some new pokemon today
i'm hyped that's all i love pokemon
presents i feel like they're always
really fun even if there are like
certain games in the pokemon universe
that i'm not super interested in or not
as much as others um
let's go ahead and watch today's pokemon
presents we're watching this on the
official pokemon youtube channel it
already has 2.3 million views let's do
it
it's muted let me try that again
let's do it okay
in today's pokemon presents we will be
sharing all the information on the
blazer shirt combo dude including the
pokemon
scarlet games
but before that i'm happy to share some
news about the pokemon world
championships that will be held in
london uk this year from august 18th to
august 21st i've been to the world
championships before and if you can go
look at this video please do it is a
good time hello pokemon trainers i'm
chris brown from the pokemon company
international unfortunately i'm
delighted to share with you updates on
our annual pokemon world championships
after three years our global community
will come together august 18th to 21st
in london for not only intense pokemon
battles but also to be together
celebrating old friendships and creating
new ones all in the spirit of friendly
competition they are really really
expecting thousands and often have
really cool um pokemon centers like
stores trading card game video game and
pokken tournament deluxe events many
players had long journeys earning their
invitation over several years and we are
thrilled to learn who will earn the
title of world champion that's all so
pretty
this year we are also adding many new
elements to the show beginning with two
new pokemon titles
please join me in welcoming pokemon go
where nearly 100 players will compete
across two age divisions oh and pokemon
users okay where six teams what would
that seven regions will compete
these players have battled all year for
their shot to earn the title of the very
first world champion like i didn't even
know that was a thing that's so cool if
you're surprised
fans attending in person including our
largest ever pokemon center their very
very shop
for those unable to attend in person you
can follow all the action from wherever
you are i still have the san francisco
one from when i went to the san
francisco world championships every
championship like um each age division
uh pokemon tournaments are held around
the world and we hope the competition at
the world championships inspire many new
players to make new friends through
battling and one more thing it's my
honor to unveil for fans today our new
pokemon world championships pikachu
trophy take a look
i would like to see it
ah
that's so cute
oh my gosh that looks really well made
we look forward to seeing you in london
and now i would like to hand it back to
mr utsonomia
all my londoners out there in it totally
go if you can thank you very much mr
brown
with the pokemon world championships
returning after three years
please look forward to exciting battles
to keep you on the edge of your seats
thank you also his no his hands are just
about use about a few of our games
it's a little bit much
you can put him away
for the first time in three years we
held in-person pokemon go fest events in
berlin and seattle i've never been to
one of those and would love to an event
in sapporo japan
playing pokemon go in japan ultra beasts
have appeared at each event
and these people super quick
was one of the best experience i've had
i was playing it sorry i was in japan
two months after pokemon go came out
so it still had hype
i think it was two months at least um
and that meant that japanese people
were playing it everywhere but would
come up to me and ask me if i had i
think it was tauros was the one most
people were asking for um basically they
were asking to trade pokemon that only
uh international regions had which was
such a cool experience because it was
like so
i don't know such a cool way to make
friends like we raided with people in
japan it was so so so much fun if you
like pokemon i never intend to go to
japan i would recommend just openly
playing it um
obviously will have died down there as
well um but it was like i'm just so i
felt so lucky to have that timing it was
it was awesome
beasts will all gather together during
the pokemon go fest 2022 finale event it
will be held on august 27th the finale
is a global event that can be enjoyed by
trainers wherever they are in the world
trainers will be able to encounter
pokemon they may not normally see in the
wild they can also encounter the
mythical pokemon shaman by completing
special research
will you be able to help recontend with
the ultra beasts
and what has become of professor willow
who was sucked into ultra space through
an ultra wormhole stay tuned for the
story's conclusion like a brutal thing
to happen to somebody that they say so
politely additionally and what happened
to that guy who got sucked into added to
the game it's a special incense that can
be used once a day and lasts for 15
minutes it can attract pokemon not
normally seen in your area and rumors
say it might even attract legendary
pokemon
use daily adventure incense for a 15
minute adventure every day
cool over the past six years we've seen
pokemon from every region you and
pokemon go there are now over 700
pokemon you can register to the pokedex
whether you're making new friends at
pokemon go fest or having i would like
to go to one of those pokemon world
championships the entire world is the
stage for pokemon go and our adventures
are just getting started
i know that first one was like a
disaster though
pokemon unite the hot app for nintendo
switch and mobile devices
pokemon unite has continued to grow and
evolve since its release one year ago in
celebration of its first anniversary
we're adding not only new pokemon and
features to the game but also many
events and campaigns
i still haven't played it i know that i
should
a new type of quick battle pika party
okay today
i'm a big fan of this guy
in this special type of quick battle in
celebration of our first anniversary all
pokemon on the field both wild and
players are pikachu
we hope oh my gosh festivities
that's so cute
oh my god additionally buzzwole will be
joining unite battles starting today
august 3rd
buzzwole is an all-rounder that can
grapple opposing pokemon and launch them
he's the thickest boy i've ever seen in
my life run amok in battle with
buzzwol's ability feast boost which
temporarily increases buzzwol's movement
speed and basic attack speed each time
it knocks out an opposing pokemon look
at the size of this absolute
anniversary is just the start of what's
to come in pokemon unite we're planning
more events for september as well so
please stay tuned
and we're gifting you all right
for pikachu
lucario blastoise snorlax and sylveon in
celebration of the first oh
oh my god that blastoise
he's a little fireman
oh my gosh
this is a cool mix into it
excuse me
hey
mm-hmm
[Music]
oh that makes sense
friendship huh
[Music]
oh that looks awesome
event detail subject to change without
notice
[Music]
what's this looks like mewtwo's back in
the pokemon cafe
that was the cafe remix intro personally
make delicious drinks indeed but i've
also played cafes
i think it looks very cute
once you make a lot of delicious drinks
and dishes in one minute cooking to film
mewtwo up it can join your staff
oh my gosh
here are some hints on how to play the
one minute cooking puzzle mode to
satisfy mewtwo
tip one gather great staff
mewtwo likes to order small plates so
gather staff that specialize in small
plates
squirtle oh my god
i really love the art style of this game
it's super cute you want to aim for the
high score try raising your pokemon like
distinct while still looking like
pokemon yeah
i appreciate the variety by training
them once your great staff is up to the
challenge it's time to begin one minute
cooking
on to the second tip but yeah this game
gameplay
once you begin one minute cooking keep
on mixing the pokemon to rack up those
combos
use these tips and make delicious drinks
and dishes and you should be able to
satisfy mewtwo we hope you'll give one
minute cooking a try and there's more
following latias who just appeared today
will also appear in the future wait
there's even more we have a special
campaign underway starting today this is
your chance to get viktini and live
on your staff let me do that pokemon
cafe remix is available sorry i should
do it at the stop it is playable on
nintendo switch systems and mobile
devices
oh my god
those are real
costumes
next up where can i get one update on
the pokemon scarlet and pokemon violet
let's go
trailer does not reflect actual gameplay
experience
[Music]
dude
[Music]
ah it's my favorite pokemon
gyarados is my favorite
please
today we begin
the treasure hunt
[Music]
travel across pal dale
confirmed their vehicles
[Music]
their little motorbikes that's why they
look so ridiculous i do not like the
look of these legendaries possibly
i know a lot of people
[Music]
dude i'm so excited for this game
[Music]
i just this is what i dreamed about as a
kid you know
i'm so glad pokemon
just for the nostalgia the fact that
it's still supported
dude the flying i wonder how limited
that is
so hot
what will you achieve he's kind of hot
too to be honest everybody's hot
with you what we'll be your pokemon
journey together
learn together
i'm really looking forward to it man
together
find something to treasure
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh my gosh i'm so excited
that comes out the same week as ragnarok
you're now starting to get a clearer
picture of your adventures to come in
the pal damn it's true
i'd like to dive a little deeper into
the information presented so let's take
a closer look together shall we yes
i'll do anything you ask
the newest titles in the pokemon series
are the pokemon scarlet and pokemon
violet games
these titles will be open world rpgs a
first for the pokemon series
sprawling landscapes and vibrant towns
weave together to form the power bayer
where your new adventure will unfold
[Music]
move across water
and glide through the sky i feel like
this is what i needed to see
i'm going to do my forms as needed while
you explore every nook and cranny of the
region with them whoa
you climbing up mountains and stuff
you will be enrolling at a certain
academy as a student
behind a desk and a special independent
study project awaits you the treasure
hunt through it you'll embark on a
journey to find treasure of your own
here in paldea
three grand stories are waiting for you
one story will revolve around the
familiar gym battles
you'll go to eight pokemon gyms and aim
for the champion rank of course in these
games there is no set path you must take
when challenging the gym i'm really
looking forward to this very own course
along victory i wonder how it'll scale
the other two stories you'll experience
hold many surprises and discoveries as
well i would like to know what's up with
that story will you begin with how will
you progress through them it is all up
to you
keep going sorry
professor sada and professor churro
research legends passed on in the paldea
region i would tell you mr cleveland is
the director of the academy you'll
attend
and mr jacques is your homeroom teacher
who teaches biology hell yeah dude
you'll have your battle loving friend
nimona
and you'll meet arvin an upperclassman
and a great cook
there's also penny a shy student in your
grade
there are gym leaders too
like grusha the ice type gym leader
the people you meet in paldeya are sure
to enrich everybody's hot what the hell
pokemon when did this become a thing
new pokemon let's go many different
species of pokemon also called the
paldaya region home
this pokemon is the paldayan regional
form of whooper of course it is it lives
on the land and covers its body with a
poisonous film oh i thought it was like
a little mud boy
our delightfully squishy pokemon that
are smooth to the touch
and here's the titan which has a large
body and a hard horn that can freeze its
surroundings so it's of course we also
have the pokemon from which you'll
choose your first partner
sprightito
fue coco
and quaxley quacksley dude i always go
i'm getting lots of pokemon waxley dude
have you seen him complete your pokedex
as part of my adventure
just unbelievable
[Music]
you can enjoy co-op play with up to
three friends
you can go look for pokemon you haven't
yet discovered
wonderful trade together race across the
map
enjoy all the paldeya region has to
offer with family and friends
[Music]
the terrastil phenomenon makes pokemon
shine like gems
[Music]
that's really cool
i wonder how many
it's so pretty all pokemon in the
paledae region are able to terrastilize
which can provide a boost to a pokemon's
type and make its moves stronger so it's
not all pokemon it's just all
pokemon from this some pokemon will
change type when they terrastilize
oh
whoa
what type they
[Music]
for example an eevee would typically
remain normal type after terrastilizing
but there could be eevee that become
grass or water type after terrastilizing
oh i get it we hope you'll try to catch
pokemon
have
tara
reed
types are more likely to appear in
terror raid battles
you can challenge terra pokemon in these
battles multiplayer three other trainers
dude this is
you can attack or heal with your own
timing without having to wait for your
allies
she's my favorite one of my favorite
pokemon too try to cooperate with your
allies to get the upper hand truly the
sexiest pokemon
look at that after you successfully
defeat a terror pokemon you'll get the
opportunity to catch it for yourself
nice
oh my god dude i'm so hyped
[Music]
we've kept all the things you love about
pokemon while evolving the adventure you
can
we hope you look forward to the day you
set out on your adventure
the pokemon scarlet and pokemon violet
games are available to pre-order at
participating retailers
is there a like periodic elective
edition or anything
your independent study in the paldea
region begins in three months my gosh
we eagerly await your enrollment me too
that's all i'm definitely gonna stream
it
thank you very much for tuning in and
watching thank you
dude so sold that looks
rad what the heck